I would also accept that not all trans
athletes are the same so some may happen
they literally are get them out get them
out gotta go on teaching others may not
so for example I know a woman don't care
get them out no exception she has an
unfair Advantage go on I want him gone
women women women what up guys welcome
to the judge pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
I'll bring that notification Bell the
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
and let's get started so today we're
going to be reacting to a Pierce Morgan
clip about a man that seriously thinks
that he can get a period guys when I
hear about this craziness sometimes I
don't think these people are real so I
definitely need to see it I think we
have a mental health crisis in the west
honestly all these people were raised in
broken families with the media basically
as their main transplant of culture and
now we just have Madness run awry before
we start guys please get to 2 000 likes
on this video all right help check out
help uh help a nice lady out all right
let's pull up the clip welcome back to
Piers The Saga of trans athletes
competing in women's sport appears to be
nearing what I would say is a common
sense conclusion at least for now images
like this a transgender swimmer Leah
Thomas that we discussed earlier kind of
crystallize the absurdity in our
fairness well certainly that's what I
think well high profile stories of
Laurel Hubbard who made the Tokyo
Olympics as a translator what the hell
just look at their jaws man ah oh my
gosh
that's so great
at the age of 43 nearly double the age
of any of the other female contestants
spot Furious debate well last week World
Athletics announced that trans athletes
will no longer be allowed to compete
against women at the end of this month
so they did it to protect fairness and
integrity of women's sport critics said
it's transphobic that's their response
to anything in this in this debate and
leaves trans women with nowhere to go
which is a fairer argument which has to
be resolved but joining me now is
British shot but Champion Emilia
strickler and human rights campaigner
Peter tatchel welcome to both of you um
Amelia we had you on before about this
and you were very passionate about why
this needed to happen so I'd imagine
you've really been pleased to see this
development percent were a lot of women
especially in athletics are really
really excited about this it's just
wait is she an athlete oh wow shop okay
I mean we're all we're we're all
thinking this like let's just uh now
making it go into Grassroots and Masters
level where there is a lot of trans
women competing in the women's category
as well so now that we've got the elite
level it needs to be all levels all
sports so Peter it's complex this
because I don't want trans athletes not
to be able to compete let me just say
that straight away I do I really do pick
a lane pick the lane you were born with
if you don't if you want to play pretend
stay out of the sports I spent some time
with Martina navratulover in Florida
last week uh who's been recovering from
double cancer and it's very moving
interview but we actually had a chat
about this as well because she's one of
the most high profile lgbtq campaigners
has ever been And yet when she raised
her head over the parapet about this and
said I just think it's a real problem
and you can't allow this to continue
otherwise women's sport will be
destroyed she then got tried to be
canceled and people abused her they
shamed her and so on which I thought was
completely ridiculous she's not a friend
of the transgender Community because
she's trying to stand up for what she
saw was an unfairness for women's rights
in spool and I just thought that was
terrible what what do you make of this
ruling by Sebastian Co and what
Athletics and how do we resolve all this
well the first principle is that sport
has to be fair
and it's not fair if people have
particular unique advantages so you
would accept that well I accept that but
I would also accept that not all trans
athletes are the same so some may
haven't they literally are get them out
get them out gotta go advantage and
others may not so for example I know a
woman a trans woman who competes in a
women's football team among the team she
is one of the smallest and weakest of
the team no don't care get them out no
exception she has an unfair Advantage go
on I want him gone and equally all
athletes in Elite Sports have some kind
of Advantage they may have extra large
lungs or hearts or long legs tall height
don't care the requirement is a woman to
be in a woman's sport women women women
um Michael Phelps that fantastic
brilliant swimmer who won so many gold
medals in the pool had it on feasibly
large wingspan yeah and right when he
put his arms out it was six inches
longer than anybody else's reach so I
mean but he also had yeah but it doesn't
even okay I'm gonna put this in
perspective guys so so when I was in
high school
um I really wanted to win a National
Championship that was like my whole goal
in life I could have went anywhere from
a division one to a division three
school just going to play in college
puts you in the top like two percent of
Athletics
um I went to the ncaas and I also played
overseas okay I was in all conference
player I got freshman of the year
um I also played basketball I ran track
um I I was all I think it was all area
or whatever it was I got all tournament
multiple times like I was a good player
for volleyball and for my position I was
short take that and I'm six foot I'm in
the top like one or two percent of
women's height and I was short I
remember wanting to be taller so I could
be like six two or six three because
that was the best height to be recruited
at on my team in high school every other
girl went to Vision one I was short on
that team and I was next to girls that
were six five now on I went to a
division three school and at that school
the men's basketball team we didn't have
a volleyball team for men but we had a
basketball team for men and the men were
like it was common to have six seven six
five was common now on the division
three women's team and that was at the
third division okay on the division
three women's team I was one of the
taller ones had the Division III Men
been into her allowed into our division
I would have had no opportunity I
couldn't even play there
and I was one of the better ones at my
school the large lung capacity right so
I've heard such Faith yeah I I think you
know it's not an invalid argument I mean
they're you know in All Sport you're
going to get some people who are
physical freaks if all of a better
phrase like Michael Phelps who literally
could do this and it's normally the same
as your height or something isn't it the
span and you had six inches extra I
should do that right if you could help
I'm in huge feet I think as well what's
what's your response to that argument
but biologically they're still the sex
that they're competing against
um you know at the end of the day
reducing a testosterone level is is not
going to cut it because women are so
much more than a testosterone level you
know physiologically you know periods
whole other whole other districts
we're so much more than a testosterone
level so just reducing a testosterone
level at the end of the day I mean it's
not going to change the physiological
difference there's a lot of these people
too are you know they're training as a
male athlete for a long period of time
before transitioning so they're having
capacity as well all these things which
you get after you know having gone
through puberty they're real things
which give most most trans athletes a an
immediate biological advantage that's my
problem
the other half of this is what what if
if they don't compete against women born
to female bodies what happens to trans
athletes now I think there's one of two
things you can do either they compete
against their biological sex which most
of them have done no I just say banum
let's just start making accommodations
for people in delusion I don't think
it's kind I don't think it's nice to
make all these accommodations for people
that are living in craziness anyway for
many years you want to be in Crazy Town
go be in crazy town but don't make me
live in your crazy town never
successfully against women which I think
is the argument right there
an entirely new category there are more
and more as you said at Grassroots level
you create an entirely new category for
Trans athletes to compete against other
trans athletes well my starting point is
there shouldn't be a blanket ban on all
trans athletes there should be
individual assessment so where there are
issues that's never going to work
disagree nope no no no no no no no no of
course it can you can't make it one you
know person by person by person by
person you can't they're not that many
trans athletes overall and it's quite
actually there are more and more of them
well and why should I have to like why
do I have to pretend they're women
that's a
is they're going to start breaking
women's records irrevocably because I
mean Leah Thomas won One race against
females that's just a point of the
argument females are 50 odd seconds I
mean it was ridiculous and then the
podium Towers over these these I mean
this Podium picture you can't no one can
be happy about that yeah that is clear
Advantage for a biological male what I'm
saying where there is a clear
demonstrable proven Advantage an unfair
Advantage then of course that should not
be allowed to take place but I do no no
no no ban
um like what are you doing is this a
trans person no what's his angle that's
what I don't understand what his angle
is probably makes money from probably
owns like a clinic that does the
surgeries or something yeah I'm like you
know what's crazy when I found out most
of the trans people are autistic like a
large percentage of them so it's like
they're basically like convincing
autistic people to chop off their parts
they get fixated on an idea yeah and
then wrong with it and that's how sad I
was like the individual assessment
rather than a blanket ban is the way to
go okay because then you you don't you
penalize the ones who do have an unfair
Advantage but you don't penalize that
ones that don't so Amelia it's
interesting because in in rugby I think
in places like New Zealand now for
example they do actually because they
recognize that some kids when they get
to 13 are twice the size of other 13
year old kids they now separate them in
weight classes rather than age so they
put the ones who are a certain size and
they they play rugby against each other
depending no this is all too confusing
no no no get them out age
so it's what Peter says he got any Merit
to do it this way I mean I I I don't
think me or many female athletes would
think that was still appropriate because
of the biological sex that is there at
the end of the day yeah there's still so
many physiological differences
they're never going to have a period
right whereas every Elite female athlete
once a month has but in some cases quite
a crippling condition which they're
going to get every month all right let's
stop convincing the man a crippling
condition we're just dramatic like
guys if you have a period that is a
crippling condition something's wrong
get that checked out it is not a
crippling condition stop whining the
training will affect conversations
competitions right which I I completely
understand when women say that that's
not going to happen to a trans athlete
no it won't so they have that Advantage
regardless of their size yeah but again
I say
don't have a blanket ban have individual
assessment I think it's particularly
unfair for intersex athletes like Casa
semenya well that's a different case but
but it's very similar because it's about
you know a mixture of male and female
and it's not something they have chosen
it's something I do feel I I feel it's
not like the the rapist situation
Scotland where I think they're literally
scamming the system I do have respect
for people who transition it's not about
being transphobic at all it's about
Caster didn't transition she was born no
I know I know I I think that's a
different case but I I think that
they're very very unique cases I mean
there's hardly any of them right well
there's the 13 that's the number in
terms of Casa smart DSD yeah sorry that
was the number I I was referring to 13
DSD athletes in the women's distance
events and three of them had
gold silver and bronze in 2016 Olympics
oh my God look at that that is so wild
what the hell
you where you know clearly they have oh
that's so sad an advantage because
they've done really really well for
themselves well they might just be very
good athletes but you know I I take them
there's a debate going on here yeah and
I think we need more science more
investigation I don't think we need any
science or any investigation I just
think it should be men and women and
that's it I think as I said it has to be
fair okay World Athletics that we've
seen the science this is why we've made
our decision we've seen the science
Peter I like your attempt to try and win
this argument but I think I don't agree
even Lord codes said he did Even though
kohi said it's not proven that they
don't have an advantage so you know it's
okay and this is like you gotta get me
on here look at this is what the libs
will do they'll cite their
studies and tell me not to believe
what's in front of my eyes
what I can see that's like whatever what
it's a negative that Lord Co and the
world Athletics Federation are seeking
to uphold and I think that's a very bad
way to go maybe but I think the best way
to do is to is to stay stop pause
continue investigating but for now
preserve the Integrity of women's sport
right I mean that's where I think yeah
give us a shot yeah please and your case
literally literally yeah ban ban man
from women's sports all right guys you
can go back ban the man I'm tired of
this I can't see it any longer this is
delusion I'm tired of these people
living in delusion and making me watch
this making me react to this and I know
I make money off of these videos but
it's like I just would like one of these
days I'd like to react to a based person
based based bass but it's like you guys
give me so much crazy in the world
anyways guys let me know what you think
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel I'll talk to you next
time